will you marry me first yes
hey [ __ ] look who's getting married
whoa
congratulations thank you so excited i'm
so happy i still haven't seen the ring
let me see it
gorgeous as you can imagine marrying
paris hilton is quite different than
what i expected may i get a hamburger
oreo mcflurry what kind of toy does the
happy meal have
that's where i used to keep my goat this
is the famous goat storage area
diamond
stop it
feel like pretty woman but not a hooker
oh i love days like this just you and me
oh you're gonna plant a honeymoon i was
thinking like swing with sperm whales
sperm
sounds uh whales big whales
she's crazy i'm the luckiest guy in the
world aren't i
yes
you're supposed to say i'm lucky too
[Music]
yolo
around weddings people go in little
cuckoos
i'm thinking i would want probably 75
people total no i'm saying my friends
party hats save the dates made what
this looks like a dog's birthday party
all the venues are getting booked up i'm
gonna end up getting married at like
chuck e cheese or something chuck e
cheese actually is the best pizza in the
world i know i love it though this is
like my wedding too he just needs to
stay in his lane i'm happy to stay in my
lane we just need you and your mom to
start moving in your lane
have you had a sit down with mom and dad
no
i still have healing to do with mom and
dad that's painful to talk about
i feel like i've lived my whole life for
other people
when is the wedding i don't know yet it
almost seems like you're stalling a
little bit i feel like paris needs a
little pushing sometimes everyone leave
me alone this is your last chance to
pull the plug on me do you like getting
cold feet i want to grow up but i make
sure
that i make the right choice
curious
no
i just don't want to be alone forever
kiss the bride
you